it's sort of a sad reality of our modern
day but one of the most effective ways
to catalyze action on climate change
might actually be to make it financially
difficult for companies that don't take
climate change seriously and along those
lines we've learned that a British firm
named legal in general which manages
about 1.2 trillion dollars in assets and
mutual funds is going to be pulling
money from companies that ignore climate
change or just generally have a bad
record when it comes to the environment
and in addition to pulling funds they'll
be naming the companies specifically and
we recently heard from Helena Morrissey
who's the head of personal investing at
the firm and she said the financial
sector needs to come together to
actually drive change I find this to be
a very refreshing attitude given that a
lot of the people in these firms have
the view of investment choice that is
basically equivalent to show me the
money and we can play devil's advocate
this with this right we can say well
it's possible that legal in general is
doing this simply for the fee for the PR
benefit right the idea is get people to
write our get media to write articles
about how they're doing this and that
will get more people to invest money
with them and they'll make more money my
response to that would be who cares
right if they're actually going to pull
funds from companies that damage the
environment I don't care if it's for PR
and it's a good move if people decide to
move assets to companies that consider
environmental impact in their
investments my only real concern is they
might be left with very few companies to
invest in in some way because obviously
we can say oh
oil companies are bad for the
environment but what about just really
big retailers who have a huge carbon
footprint like Amazon because they're
shipping a single bar of soap fully
across the country right like is that
good for the environment or bad and if
you really think about what it means to
be good or bad for the environment I
don't know how many companies you're
ultimately going to have left but I
still think that it's a great decision
there's another counterpoint I've read
to this which is that oh it's all lovely
and daisies and waterfalls and Ginger
Snaps
but if you invest with your heart
instead of with your mind you will lose
I would make the case that you're not
actually investing with your heart if
you think it's important to invest
sustained
right because what will your investments
be worth if we totally destroy our
environment that's gonna be bad for the
economy that's going to be bad for
humanity and it's gonna be bad for all
companies eventually so I think that if
you're thinking beyond this quarter or
this year the real way to invest
thoughtfully is to invest sustainably I
think investing with your heart would be
like moving your investments to
companies with the most sentimental TV
commercials or something like that
that's not what we what's what's being
done here actively moving your money to
companies that are conscious of their
environmental impact I think is actually
investing with your mind and I've been
thinking about more and more of this
personally I mean we've talked before
Pat about my investment philosophy which
is by long-term and hold the most
diversified possible set of stocks and
usually I mean people know I just used
the companies Vanguard and betterment
they have super super low fees I don't
pick stocks
I don't time the market I just want to
have a little extra money I buy a total
stock market index fund and I let it
ride I'm obviously invested in some oil
companies as a result of that because
I'm invested in the entire market I
think if you know I hold tiny amounts of
stocks but if the real big player
started doing this it actually could
influence company policy thanks for the
full disclosure now we know how this
affects your commentary yes which I
guess is not at all right yeah I don't
even know what I own I just know I own
the entire stock market I the other
thing by the way is that well I I'm
jumping the gun Pat but if you allow me
just a moment we might have a new
partnership related to this generally to
announce at some point okay yeah Pat
looks confused I don't have anything to
announce today but I will at some point
and I think people will be very very
interested to hear more about that but
good move by legal in general I support
this the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad